welcome we do have a quorum and welcome
to the retirement benefits
commission
okay the uh minutes of our previous
meeting were distributed and they're
posted on the website are there any
comments or
Corrections move to approve second all
right moved by Senator gray seconded by
representative Packard any
discussion those in
favor
opposed all right thank
you that's fine you you were not here so
that make
sense all right so we had got some some
suggestions from a number
of um members in and the first one is
multiplier changes we got sen Senator
gray had one proposed and it has been
costed Mr real presented some other
other changes that we can consider as
well um but first
Senator uh certainly I would like to
speak to the rationale behind what I
propose um when various members
uh that were in favor of the house bill
uh that came over in
hb2 um they said that retention was a
big issue and that doing house build to
was going to uh solve or help to solve
the retention issue uh when I looked at
that I said
well uh it doesn't do anything for
anyone except for those people in that
uh that space uh that
were uh
members or or employed by the state but
not vested at the time the legislation
was changed
previously so looking at that and
looking at the cost estimat that I got I
says well if it's a retention issue then
I need to affect all the members in
group
two not just the at that time uh
1,824 people
and so if you look at the revised update
that you guys got at the top of page two
is what I asked the retirement system to
cost out for
me and that was a plan that for all of
group
two both the people who were and were
not hired at the time we did the last
change to increase by
uh
0.25% uh their retirement up to uh a
total of
2.5 and then at 30 years that would have
happened at 20 years and then at 30
years it would go up another
0.25% so bringing those people up to a
2.5 again looking at trying to do
something for retention not only for the
employees in that Gap but for the
employees that were uh affected or or
hired after that uh because truly if
it's a retention issue uh my problem
with retention isn't going to go away
with the people in that Gap it's going
to continue on
further and so to do something for them
um again the years that this multiplier
changes
uh could be adjusted it could be that
you bring it to 2.5 at 20 years it could
be that you bring it to
2.25 at 20 and then go to 2.5 at 25
years there was a wide range but each
one of those uh would have a various
varying cost but that proposal doesn't
do anything for the cola which is the
other issue that was brought before me
all right and that that is for the cola
EXC me Senator we're talking about Cola
separately if that's well you say this
this proposal doesn't affect colas it it
it relates to the plan uh Madam chair
and if I might have a a little bit and
the reason why you know
that the two of them together is an
expense and so to try to get to that
total expense I kind of need to speak to
both at the same
time and
so
in the system that we have right now
there is no match you can make voluntary
contributions okay I certainly did that
when I was working for the federal
government and you know I have enough
money in there that uh it certainly is
worthwhile and so by having that account
and having a match up to say a 5% and
taking and funding that out of
salary because it would be funded as a
uh benefit so it would come out the same
way you would negotiate a salary and
have the groups being able to say well I
want a 4% raise I'll take one in match
I'll take three in salary or whatever
you negotiate and so the two of those
together and if you look at the cost
estimate on the top of your sheet that
was about 15
million and if I look at at the estimate
and again it was not a hard and fast
number because uh that I got from the
administrative Services people they said
it was around 13 to5 million that if
everyone that was a state employee took
the match and we matched it it would be
about that
same okay so the two of them
together would be around $30
million 15 it would be in in the first
year because that that uh the one for
the match would continue on past then
but again it would happen the same way
the salaries would so those two together
um to me was a significant change and
would help retention and would do a lot
of the things that people asked me to do
when looking at house bille to thank you
m CH
okay thank
you
does anyone have any comments or
questions on this this plan Mr
real thank you madam chair I would have
a a question for Senator gray if he'd be
willing to take it absolutely um so
Senator gray in your first proposal um
you mentioned wanting to do this because
we wanted to impact change for all
members of the system which I can uh
fully appreciate and I think that uh
everyone in this room can do that um but
your second proposal would only only
impact state
employees and um I'm not sure that we
would want to have uh at least from from
the firefighters perspective uh further
discussion on a a program that would
only affect a a certain number of people
even within that um either slotting
scale or the full system when we talk
about uh employee matches that exist now
at the local level and we can do that
now in fact it's being done uh in the
city of over currently and it has been
done for uh over 20 years I believe um
so that exists now um so I'm not sure if
your proposal if I'm misunderstanding it
or if it would just only impact state
employees uh thank you um when I was
researching this um I was not told I was
told that there would need to be
statutory authority to be able to do the
match okay uh again because it wasn't
didn't come out as a formal proposal uh
but the state employees are the only
ones that I can do negotiate benefits
with or you know have them uh the cities
and towns would be free to do whatever
they choose to do um again it separates
it from the retirement system so yeah if
the local governments wanted to do it
and again your local firefighters if
they came in and said okay we want a 6%
raise but we're willing to take 2% in
match and whatever and hopefully your
your Dober firefighters have already you
know gotten to there so maybe you know
they're ahead of the game but um that is
not the case as far as I was told in any
other community uh because I wasn't even
told about Dober so um again I you know
I'm trying to make make sure that that
I'm offering things to to various people
okay the first proposal on the adding
the percentage would affect all group
two this proposal here on um the match
would affect every state employee
everyone okay I can't talk to the local
ones because I don't have any control
over them for
benefits
okay any other questions
comments okay Mr real would you like to
present the other multiplier changes you
suggested thank you madam chair I will
try and be brief here there's there's
two multiplier changes here uh they are
very similar to one another uh it builds
off of uh some Concepts that were
discussed at the last meeting regarding
um some sort of incentive for
retention and uh it also is a is a bit
of a spin-off from Senator Bradley's
amendments that he presented essentially
the the change here would be um to
Senator Bradley's amendment that a
member would only receive the uh two and
a half%
multiplier uh for every year of service
should they reach their required age and
years of service as it is under current
law uh if I'm not mistaken the current
proposed amendment uh was to include the
2.5%
multiplier uh for everyone in that
sliding scale regardless of when they
left the system um but I think it has
the potential to decrease the cost uh
some
amount uh if we take into consideration
those that potentially leave before
their required time and age um for
whatever the reason may be either on
vested deferred retirement uh disability
or removing their money from the system
alog together so um I would propose that
we look at the costs uh of doing this to
see if there's a decrease to the $92
million uh price tag on the original
Senator Bradley
Amendment and number two well sorry I'd
like to see if there any discussion on
that that sounds very very sensible to
me because
we're um it will obviously save money
for
those those people who leave early would
not get the full full benefit of the
change any other comments
questions Senator Bradley you have a
comment I think anything that makes it
more cost effective
would be a good thing so um I think if
we're going to look at it
i' want to ask Mr Carlin
whether this
proposal um can be looked at by GRS
without having to do a entire new
Actuarial
analysis
thank you Senator Bradley for the record
Marty Carlin from
nhrs uh an answer to your question uh we
I can I we can pose that question to GRS
uh for an impression on an order of
magnitude on what this may affect the
cost they wouldn't give us a number or
percentage without a full Val but uh we
can brooch the question so um
um commissioner will if if um or the
chair somebody can send us the exact
wording of The Proposal we can I
approach that the GRS and since it's not
a full
analysis possibly could get you the
answer for next week if not you know
then not long after that because it
would would have to be a cost decrease
even if only one person retired without
reaching the age of um yeah or
whatever so
yes mi Mr R and I will work out what the
specific language should that you should
talk to GRS about after this meeting
yeah so if I can just ask
that um I think Mr R when you talked
about it you talked about the amendment
of 2.55% for everybody I think it should
be analyzed on the 2.5 as well as the
split 2.25 and
2.5
okay
thanks okay so anyone
else any your next next comments um the
next multiplier uh recommendation is
very similar to the first uh the only
change here is that uh it would impact
to Senator Gray's Point everyone in the
system obviously the cost would be uh
significantly higher uh but the formula
would be the same um in that the uh
members hired after July 1 2011 would
receive
2.25% for all years of service but again
only if they reach their required age
and years of service which as we all
know uh for that group is 25 years uh
and age 52 and a half uh in order to
collect so it essentially be the same
calculation um and the reason I thought
that these might work uh and then and
then full disclosure that might be part
of a a longer term discussion and that's
fair um when we look at the cost of that
but the reason these came up is uh the
numbers as we're looking at them now and
Mr Carlin can correct me if I'm mistaken
but we're somewhere around 1730 members
in that sliding scale uh and when we
were having these discussions last year
um it was 100 m numbers more than that
um
so uh you know when we look at those
that are currently retirement eligible
in that sliding scale um by my simple
firefighter math uh somewhere around
1,500 or so uh we estimate have not
actually reached reached their required
age uh eligibility and time in service
so we think this could potentially work
uh when we look at the people that are
leaving
early
any comments
concerns all
right so this has two differences if I
understand correctly the first is that
it's based on the um two and a quarter
percent for one group in the Gap and the
other is it extends to all current hires
at the two and a half 2 and a qu% level
is that
correct correct essentially um if you
were in that sliding scale uh then this
proposal would be the same as the first
and anyone hired uh that was not a part
of that sliding scale um would go to a
two and a quarter
perc they're currently at uh 2% okay
thank you any other questions or
concerns
terms
um anything
else does anyone else have a proposal or
a comment we should discuss on the
multiplier
issue Senator Susi no okay all right so
we will work on the specifics of this
proposal for GRS so that it can be at
least costed
roughly
and Mr Fuller has presented a
number of other
changes
um I'd like to not do number one the
cola account until we get to cola's so
so that's fine fine number two yes with
uh number two and thank you madam chair
um and these with these proposals here I
mean some of them are going to be you
know just group one or you know both
groups and I also acknowledge too that
some of these are more of the short-term
versus long-term variety so there's
definitely quite a mix in here so I
wanted to acknowledge that in terms of
things we could potentially do in the
short term versus potentially things for
the long term for this one right here
with uh actually with with with making
this change
um one big benefit I see in this is that
it would
allow more people in the group and I
think if more people are in the group I
think that would definitely be a benefit
yes there' be more more people down the
road that would also be eligible for
benefits but if more people are actually
paying into the group I think that's a
good thing because I know one thing that
we've talked about here is you know
money and funding and you know things
cost money so I think if more people are
paying into the system by making that so
that now you know so right now it's it's
30 hours to be in there if you lower it
down to 20 and just kind of knowing too
that our the picture of how people that
are working within the the system is
changing you know and there are more
people that are kind of doing it later
on maybe they do a career they kind of
come into it later on the life and this
kind of knowing too they would be able
to potentially get a benefit I think it
works on both ends and it also would
bring more people in and I think it it
works on both the attraction and the
retention angle end so that would be um
I think some of the benefits there um I
don't if you I can stop there or keep on
going or I believe there might be some
comments Mr Ford do you have a
comment you heard me earlier um I think
one of the the oh uh thank you um one of
the things that I would submit on the 20
hours a week and and we looked at that
when we first got this in in BO we run
our own buses for example our own
transportation
um which a lot of districts don't a lot
of the drivers that I have are already
retired maybe collecting a pension
lowering the threshold to 20 hours would
make all or at least most of my drivers
eligible for retirement and would kind
of impact um where I'm already looking
for for drivers um the other you know
impact for us is going to be in food
service we have a number of employees
who will come in do a little bit of prep
serve and a little bit of cleaning four
hours a day four and a half hours a day
all of those employees in Food Service
would be also eligible under this
proposal to be in the retirement system
that's a self-funded program um we're in
a lot of districts uh those programs
don't make money and are offset by
transfers from the general fund um so
those two things would be a little
hesitation I think from my perspective
um from school
districts
Senator Greg uh are those employees that
we're talking about currently covered
under Social Security and not the
retirement
system so all of our employees in the
school district we pay social security
on is that your question yeah so I don't
I don't have uh any uh you know group
two members who like a lot of police and
fire my understanding is don't employers
don't pay social security on that every
single employee that I have currently in
both districts that I work for we play
employer Social
Security Senator BR uh so if we're
looking at a match to being able to to
do contributions uh that would also
augment their retirement system uh or
the benefits they would get at
retirement yeah and I have a concern
about that
20 hour a week limit because because if
I remember correctly that was imposed by
the federal government as a requirement
for health insurance and other benefits
so if you've got people that you are
choosing to to keep part-time so they
don't get benefits adding this benefit
does not make sense to me it would make
more sense if you were to make a
contribution to a defined benefit
Retirement System
separately from their
pay Mr martines thank you um I'd like to
um to state that I agree with that
proposal number two I think it's very
important we you know the way things are
you could end up with everybody
part-time no benefit no insurance nobody
staying on the job impossible to hire
teachers that's what's happening with
other positions in the state in fact I
would like to apply this and if if he
agrees to to every employee of a New
Hampshire retirement system participant
employer we do have a lot of workers
that work in toe booths liquor store
they do part-time jobs we have disp
positions there are 40 hours and we cut
that in 220s with no benefits it becomes
impossible to train retain knowledge and
keep anybody in fact our unfilled
positions are at alltime higher higher
than ever
so I think this is very important I
think it can be done I think we should
look at it and I think we should try to
uh to make this happen thank you madam
chair and I
will anyone
else Mr fer yes if I if I could just
comment on your um I could be mistaken
here but in ter I I understand your
concerned about the um added benefits
but my understanding is that just
because they would be entitled to
retirement benefits I mean the threshold
would stay the same in terms of being
titled to other benefits I mean just
because they could do retirement
benefits doesn't mean that all of a
sudden they would be eligible for health
insurance but I I could be mistaken but
that's just my understanding of health
benefits anything else just wanted to
make that one big comment and to uh
refer to what you were saying I I would
not be opposed of um naturally I'm
coming from a teacher perspective but at
the same time um I know I'm like you I'm
open to things that could benefit all of
us so um and whether it benefits a
certain group I mean that's fine too but
if we can look at things that could
benefit um you know multiple different
groups of employees I would not be
opposed to that at all mam chair if I
could just yes quick one continue thank
you uh this is also very important for
there are a lot of folks that have
deferred benefits in there and they are
no longer working a full-time job and
this would be a way that they would go
back to contributing to the retirement
system and it will be a win-win for
everybody be win for employers employees
you know and the community I'll say this
would only grow the pension in a
positive way so I think this is a move
in the right direction thank
you anyone else have a
comment Senator so I think the threshold
that was
adopted um for the higher number of
hours was there for a reason um I I I
tend to think this is going to
significantly drive up costs um for
property taxpayers so I think we should
be pretty cautious about
it okay Senator Bray can we get the
retirement system to comment on that
whether it would drive up costs or
potentially drive up costs I guess from
from looking at it to my perspective it
it would be a benefit to the retirements
system if these people never became
vested because they would start to
contribute but once they become vested
it should be a break even for the
retirement system and I would like to
hear your comments on
that thanks thanks for the question
Senator gray um well you know right now
um membership is for full-time permanent
employees
as the way the statute defines uh
eligible membership um we have
administrative rules that Define minimum
participation standards for the
different groups uh for employees it's
either 35 or 37 and a half hours a week
uh for teachers it's 30 um
paraprofessionals fall under 35 hours a
week unless the district opts to um
petition to add them at 30 as
contributing members uh group two it's
full-time as defined by the employer uh
because of the nature of the shifts with
the group two so there's there's
different minimum participation
standards right now um our contribution
rates are assessed as a percentage of
covered payroll so there's the cost to
pre fund the benefit the the unfunded
piece and then the medical subsidy piece
and our payrolls is about $3 billion um
for active contributing members right
now Statewide uh if you were adding
payroll of part- timr to that um you
know initially you know they'd be paying
the rates that were previously
calculated and that would be more money
coming in as we go through two-year rate
Cycles the um uh you know as there's
more money coming in it may impact the
total percentage of the rates for the
different groups but you know you you're
bringing more people in so so the
employees would be paying more because
they have more payroll as part of the um
part of the retirement system so um you
know that that's you know how how that
would impact the unfunded rate on a
larger payroll portion or what the
normal cost would be calculated for for
a part-time because a couple other
questions that come up with that is is a
part-time recruting a full Year's worth
of retirement service you know somebody
could theoretically work 29 years as a
part-time one year as a full-time and
get a 30-year pension on their you know
their average final salary or is it is
there prata uh based on the hours work
there's a lot of bookkeeping and
accounting things that you know aren't
insurmountable with that but that's a
question uh question for our group two
commissioner they know uh there are
definitions and police standards of
full-time and part-time certification so
if you had a law enforcement that didn't
beat this they have to be a certified
law enforcement to be in group two how
would sort of a special police who you
know does crowd control at the school
assembly be considered for membership
ship there's a lot of nuts and bolts in
there but the your larger question about
costs is you'd be paying in on a larger
percentage of payroll so you know
there's more money coming in that way
and how that's going to wash out you
know over time you know whether the the
ultimate um how much that is it would be
very hard to
project
thank any other questions or comments on
this
okay all
right your your number three is vesting
yes thank you um so as far as um vesting
so um The Proposal here would be to make
this threshold of five years of of
credible service so um and just I just
noted here too that um you know with our
close neighbors here that is their
threshold is is five years so again um
You' be again another way to um attract
people and also not lose them to others
so to be able to make that threshold a
little bit lower so that when they're
actually um vested in there because uh
it would make New Hampshire a lot more
attractive place to work um within the
the different groups and systems where
it' be police fire teachers whatever
else I mean just looking at lowering
that would be I think definitely an
attraction and you know a fear of mine
is that we're losing people to our to
our neighbors and I think if that way it
just makes it a much more makes uh
working in New Hampshire much more
attractive lowering that threshold and
it's also matching it up where where
others are at
too thank you and does anyone have a
comment or question Mr camper um just as
far as um you know I could see see how
some people might read that as hey I'm
gonna do five years and and get out of
here I think that's actually um not
going to be the case I think it would be
a helpful retention tool because right
now people that are already here in the
system um don't have a great sense of
security with it do the changes that
that were made about 10 years ago and um
them knowing that you know I've got five
years in the system I am now I guess
considered vested I'm not sure that
there's even an actual definition of the
term vesting um so you know if we could
perhaps uh you know cify that and give
them a greater sense of security that
you know I can do five years for the
state I don't need to worry about um you
know potential changes I think that
would be a good thing for uh for the
retention problems that we seem to be
having throughout this state
thank you Senator gray um again I'd like
to get the New Hampshire retirement
system back up to the microphone uh the
effect of vesting if I leave before I am
vested I believe I can take out the
money that I've contributed but not any
of the match uh if I leave afterward
that uh there's some kind of and I'm not
exactly sure why and that's one of the
reasons I wanted to get you up here uh
and that if if I'm well below 62 or some
age that uh I have to wait until that
retirement age before so again before we
we make a decision on this one certainly
understanding what those criteria what
it means to the system and what it means
to the employee important sure thing
thank you senator for the question um
you know when we do our member education
presentations the way we refer to
vesting is vesting means you've earned
the right to a future retirement benefit
so right now it's 10 years in New
Hampshire so somebody who has 10 years
of service um you know as a full-time
contributing member is vested in the
system um they may be 32 years old they
may be 59 you know it depends on when
they started and and what kind of breaks
and service they have so somebody being
vested doesn't mean you can collect the
benefit right away you need to age into
the requirements in the respective
groups and in the respective tiers as to
when you become eligible ible for a
service or an early retirement things
like that so but but it's you know
you've got that marker in the sand I've
got something coming to me someday you
know um and um you know people may um
you know a longer or shorter vesting
period May incentivize people to well
it's only I've been here three not crazy
about the job maybe I'll stick it out a
couple more to get vested maybe they
like the job better in two years I mean
I just from personal experience talking
to to friends and and folks I run into
you know with 10e vesting you know
members are aware of that and if they've
got like nine years they probably don't
really want to leave you know no matter
what's going on because it it
incentivizes them that there's something
for them um regardless of um if you
terminate employment regardless of
whether you're vested or not um you have
you have the option to either leave your
funds with the retirement system either
you know in anticipation of returning at
some point or whatever um and those fund
get interest credited on them on a
statutory formula so if you left your
contribution with nhrs regardless of
Market outcomes it wouldn't the interest
rate can't be any lower than zero in the
statute so you're not going to lose
money so all of the money you put in is
there um there there is really no
employer match in the sense of the way
you think about that in the 401K World
um you know the the employers contribute
to the fund but those contributions
aren't you know tied to a specific
member you know they're not paying the
percentage for you know steveen Mary and
Joe they're paying collectively for all
of their payroll base and those employer
funds which are also uh pulled and
invested are used to pay everyone's
benefit so really the only way you get
quote the employer contributions back is
if you retire and then you outlive what
you contributed to the system you know
which tends to be on average about 5 to
seven years basically you think about
the money and average worker is putting
in over their 20 or 30-year career plus
the interest accured on that and the
investment income um you know after a
certain point you know that if that was
a private sector plan once you exhausted
your savings you have zero this is a
lifetime benefit um so the trust fund
assets which the employer money goes
into is what pays that benefit if that
person lives to 100 and the reason that
kind of sort of works with a a large
Pension Plan like this is for everybody
who lives to 100 is going to be the
unfortunate person you know who dies a
month or two after they retire so you
know actuar you know that's that's how
the the funding is predicated on that
pulled um member assets um you can also
if you terminate employment you know
after a certain um frame you can request
a refund of your accumulated
contributions plus any interest so okay
I got laid off I quit I'm moving acoss
to California whatever and you know you
have a few thousand within HRS and
contributions if you don't want to leave
them there you would just fill out some
paperwork and you can roll that over
into another uh qualified retirement
plan with no tax impact on the
withdrawal we can cut you a check and
you're going to pay income tax plus a
penalty on that if you're too young um
or you can just leave it with us so that
those are the options all members
have thank you you Mr
real Mr Carlin um
would the benefit that a member receives
be relative to the years of service they
put in meaning someone that came on into
this into the system now who has to work
25 years to get 50% of their average of
their top five years if they were to
leave after 5% their benefit when
they're eligible to collect it would be
relative is that not absolutely really
good point thank you yeah so so when
when you know discussions of the
multiplier you think about that is
that's the percentage of your average
salary that you're getting for each year
that you worked so you know like a brand
new group to higher tomorrow for
instance you know if they work 25 years
at a 2% multiplier it's 50% of their AFC
after 25 years if you had fiveyear
vesting somebody worked for five years
and left 5 time 2 is 10 so they they
their ultimate benefit when they age
into qualifying for it would be 10% of
their AFC so the more the more years you
work the bigger your benefit's going to
be
yes
followup would there
be
um excuse me I think of the way to to
word this here so if a member were to
leave after five years if the vesting
were five years would there be
variables uh that would
impact the cost to the system or would
the costs essentially not
change um I I don't believe the cost
would change because it it's you know if
if someone was terminated and once we
had all their final pay reported you
know we know what their average final
compensation was going to be and that's
not going to change you know how many
years they worked and what the
multiplier was I mean I I suppose if
somebody and invested deferred in active
status if the multiplier were increased
or decreased and they had yet to retire
you know that could impact the benefit
but assuming the statutory Provisions
don't change um you know but if if they
do that that could have an impact very
rarely and and not not So Much Anymore
in the low interest interest environment
we've seen occasionally in the past
we've seen people who you know went into
vested deferred status in the 80s or 90s
uh when interest rates were higher and
their interest on their accumulated
contributions was greater than what
their retirement benefit would have been
under the formula so we calculate it you
know based on their their accumulated
contributions it's essentially a
self-funded benefit but that that hasn't
happened um in many years
now Mr martines thank you madam chair um
we strongly support that proposal number
three for fiveyear vesting I think this
is really a win-win it adds value to the
retirement system
it improves Recruitment and Retention
and helps promote a good thing I think
that we should do this and I strongly U
recommend that and thank you for
bringing this up thank
you anyone else have a
comment
okay moving
on
yes uh thank you uh number four uh so
earnable compensation so uh proposing to
uh to add back into the um to formula
because of course about you know 10 or
so years ago those um payments were uh
were no longer allowed so naturally if
you U for those that were vested prior
to that time they're still eligible for
payments but for the last 10 years
people that were vested during that time
were not so to be able to add back in
those um end the care your payouts um
and just looking at it too because again
just looking at for the theme of of
retaining employees um that would really
be I think a strong tool to be able to
retain employees to be able to uh and
and it was something that was in there
for quite some time so to be able to I
think add because again we're I think
we're looking at these issues with
attraction and retention for for a
reason so I think you know we the
pendulum went a little bit too far so if
we can kind of bring some more of these
ideas back I think we'll we'll find
we'll have a much easier time to uh
retain employees if that um benefit is
added back
in okay thank you does anyone else have
a
comment we get um Mr Carin up yes
please Mr
Carlin spiking glad I sat close to the
microphone so um any thoughts on what
this is going to do
to the system
costs um the not specifically with group
one but you know some of the proposals
uh last year on the grid um dealt with
changes to both or either average final
compensation on a lower average or
restoring uh some or all of those pay
types into uh average final compensation
and in either according to the the
analysis on the group two sides it
should translate over it would add to
the system costs
essentially folks will be getting better
benefits under those changes so then you
know the the funding for that would be
reflected in the
rates Senator gray um if I look at this
one that and uh the 20h hour proposal
number two together that an employee
could be hired on as one of these
20-hour employees
for a number of years and then be
promoted to the Cook or the whatever and
be a full-time employee and it seems
like I would get back into that
situation that you were talking about
prior to that is that a person could
work a majority of their career at a
very low number of hours but still get
full credit because we're only looking
at the high X number of years and that
would affect the benefits going going up
or going
further yeah that that um as I as I said
that you know how would you treat the
part-time service would it be a prata
you know half a year for you know if
there's an hourly threshold that which
it becomes you know full-time units work
things like that I I don't know off the
top of my head but I I I do believe um
some states or some sub plans within a
state may have some part-time Provisions
I can try to look and see if I see and
if the there was a a desire to move
forward with that idea I would I would
strong as just looking at how other
states who do that how they handle that
it may not be the best way or may not be
the way New Hampshire wants to do it but
it would be sort of a baseline to to
look at how those types of questions are
are answered Mr martines Madam chair
thank you and uh as I understand nobody
here is proposing that when you go
part-time this is going to be a
classification that you carry for the
rest of your life this is a lot like
Social Security if you have a good ear
you have a good ear then another good
ear maybe a smaller year and in the end
you have a pro-rated amount according to
what you paid in that's how the program
works this is how it's going to work for
this and I think this is a very good
thing mathematically this makes
sense thank you Senator gray just a
comment on Mr Martinez when you go and
figure out what social security benefits
are going to be there is a multiplier
that the Social Security Administration
has come up with for all of the years up
to the year of your retirement and so
that if you have a very small year okay
and that multiplier is high but you know
again because it is additive and they
they take an average of all of that it's
all of the years which again if you were
saying that I was going to take all of
the service and do the calculation that
way I would be more interested in this
proposal than looking at the High three
or high five okay and again like I say
social security looks at every year if
you worked for 40 years they look at 40
years then they take the high 30 years
of that and then they do the calculation
so just as one that's on Social Security
you know I yes thank you I know all we
all Mr
Ford hi Marty how are you you do uh can
I uh can you uh explain how School
District years of service are counted
now so like for example a teacher Works
187 188 190 days or whatever basically
10 months and then a person like me
works in the central Office I work all
12 months 261 days how are those years
of service calculated by you right now
the retirement system sure thing yeah um
teachers who are working on under
contractor are considered 10-month
employees typically you know not always
the contracts you know 91 to 6:30 of the
following you know it mirrors the school
year um and for those te teachers with a
contract get a full year of service you
know for the school year worked if they
do um summer school or something like
that they don't get extra service you
can't earn more than a year in a
calendar year um you know but um that's
how that works for uh employees like Mr
for who are full-time you know 12 months
of the year they get a year of service
for their 12 months you know so when
when when the acrs you know it's you
know it's a for a teacher it's you know
0.1 for each month in the school year
it's
0.833 for everybody else so that the
acrs end up being the same you can't get
more than a year for a year unless you
have two full-time
jobs I
see Miss
Stacy thank you so I can tell you that I
I I don't support this I think that it
was going to Cost U more money to the
employers the employers share I know
that one of the retention tools that we
use at Rockingham County is we have
significant longevity pay that people
get um and to and and and the employees
are happy but obviously if this becomes
part of the calculation we're going to
be having to pay more in so I can't I
can't support this
all I have a concern that normally the
employer contributions are paid in over
the entire career based on the payroll
and therefore they have 20 or 30 or 40
years to grow this is a payment that is
made at the very last minute and they
won't even earn any interest on the
employer contribution for it but it
boosts the pension
so it doesn't seem to me like a sensible
way for retention unless the employer
decides to start
paying a a portion of it prior to the
last year to the retirement system which
is what I believe the actuaries will
calculate yeah uh representative McGuire
um right right what what the x is refer
to to those sort of large payments at
the end in the assumptions is a load
Factor so another for instance you know
the TR members you know under entally
quote the old plan pre2 11 you know they
are getting you know uh payout of uh
unus leave vacation other earned time
possibly um you know sick pay as well uh
in in that as a lumpsum maybe you know
as well as a severance or retirement
incentive and those are averaged into
their High three and um you know there's
a so even though the the rates are
Blended among all the tiers there are
you know there's a higher load factor
for those to account for that so if all
the member tiers were moved back into
that model then that load Factor would
apply to a larger percentage and you
know that would the rates would would be
higher you know for all for that you
know you know based on past experience
the assum the actuary can assume what
those look like you know um and and they
they also know if they don't count and
and with payouts like that just just to
clarify if um again this is draw drawing
on some of our educational presentations
is if you are if you're entitled to that
under your CBA your personnel policy or
anything like that you know the vacation
payouts or whatever sick leave you're
going to get that money the difference
is for the people who were invested
prior to one one of 12 it doesn't count
in their AFC formula they neither they
nor the employer pay contributions on
that money um you know but you know it's
you know we're not the law doesn't tell
the employer they can't get that it just
the lot says we can't count
it okay okay anyone else Mr
Fuller thank you actually I just wanted
to return back to a prior comment with
the uh I think proposal number two
because I know we've been kind of going
back and forth but um I know it's not in
there because obviously it's not all the
way drawn out but I can appreciate the
concerns about a part-time employee then
getting like a full-time you know
retirement benefit and that's not the
intent of the proposal so um I would
certainly agree that there would need
definitely need to be some sort of
safeguards in that area in terms of
because I'm not advocate ating or
advancing that someone works for 20
years parttime and then that they work
one year full-time and they get the full
benefit I mean that's not the intent of
the proposal I mean to me if someone's
working part-time then essentially they
should get a part-time retirement
benefit if you work full-time you get a
full-time retirement benefit at least
that's that's the intent of where I'm
coming from and um more than happy to
work on details or whatever else but I
just wanted to the devil is in the
details and that would have quite a few
to make sure that it did what you wanted
without unintended consequences that's
fair all right anyone
else okay um
AFC yes proposal number five thank you
madam chair uh to change the uh AFC to
the highest of three years for all
members again this is going back to some
of the changes that were made as of uh
201 12 so um and I'm I don't have it on
your pardon me but I believe we changeed
it to five so to just to get it back to
three again so um this would definitely
be a added benefit to employees because
be able to because uh you know in the
last 10 years obviously those benefits
have uh gone down quite a bit with the a
raising it up to the average five versus
the average three so bringing it back to
the largest three and one other point
that I would like to make as well is
that just in looking at um you know most
large public employer plans three is
standard so uh if anything else having
five is more of the outlier and so just
again looking to um you know to attract
and retain employees knowing that that
sort of benefit would be there I think
would be a really good move on upart
okay Senator Bradley you had a
comment yes thank you um I understand
where you're coming from but this was
one of the key reforms to curb pension
spiking um that was adopted 12 years ago
so I would be opposed to it I think it
would um bring back the ability to spike
a pension and again I'd be
opposed Mr Martine thank you madam chair
uh just to be clear calculating an
average of three years is not spiking a
pension that's the way we always
calculate them before we reduce those
benefits to five so this is just a fair
way that you're going to have two people
working next to each other and the only
difference between them is that one was
hired before the other and they get more
benefits because somebody's benefit was
reduced uh I think I believe in Fair pay
for equal work if you're doing equal
work as a person next to you then your
pen should be calculated the same way as
you are because why should you create a
different class of of Citizen getting
paid different so when we calculate a
pension in three years we always
calculate penion three that is until
2011 when we overreacted and some of
this Bill had some drastic benefit
reduction to uh as a cost saving that
this you know disproportionately
affected a number of people that have
been a promised and were performing in
their jobs with the expectation that
they're going to have some benefits so I
think the right thing to do is fix what
we broke and I think the fix isn't the
legislature we can do this
thank you okay Senator Susi thank you
madam chair I I just have to
respectfully disagree with my colleague
from the Senate um the threeyear to
fiveyear was not what eliminated spiking
yet another term that we don't actually
Define but the idea was that there was a
period of time where people were working
extra details or working more
overtime reducing that and capping that
is what reduced increasing your pension
it's not whether you calculate the years
over three years or five years so I just
respectfully disagree um they're two
very different things and I I certainly
would be open to considering this
proposal okay anyone else Mr BR uh I
have a question for Mr Carlin if he was
willing to take it um the when we saw
the the the higher pensions back prior
to the 2011 changes um it was my
understanding that a lot of those
changes came from uh or excuse me a lot
of the increases at the end of the
career over a top
three uh had a lot to do with the buyout
for unused vacation and sick leave is
that accurate uh there were some I I I
can't speak for all you know the
pensions back then but there were some
high-profile incidents of Fairly large
pensions that were driven by the way
those those payouts were um timed out
over a period of years so they wouldn't
exceed the 150% cap and then there was a
case where possibly the person their
pension was L larger than their base
salary because the the way that the
community allowed it to be structured
the payouts things like that so so that
was definitely one of the driving pieces
in the debate um you know back in the
late 2000s early 2010s for sure follow
up M follow uh are
there uh it's kind of a loaded question
because I think I know the answer to it
but uh there are other safeguards in
place um to prevent what Senator
Bradley's worried about um what we
referred to commonly as spiking are
there other safeguards in place whether
it be contribution or excuse me uh
limits or the way we use our calcul
ations to determine whether or not
spiking is going to occur or not yeah
yes and and I I I'll concur with with
Senator Susi that there is really no
mutually agreed upon definition of of
spiking it there was a lot of eye on the
beholder there I I neither I nor the
retirement system would be willing to
Define it um for different people but
but what you're asking about is the 150%
earnings limitation uh and this is a
provision that was put in back in the
early 90s uh and what it says is your
last year of earnable compensation that
last 12-month block um can't be more
than 150% of your next highest year you
know in in your AFC any earnings over
that 150% limit are excluded from the
pension formula obviously if you made
more money you'd be paid for that um and
for the the tier a people that last 12
months includes any end of career
payouts those get folded into to that
last year so that's where that kind of
drove that up people could kiss the cap
you know the sort of the first way
people might sort of picture that is I'm
going to work you know 20 hours of
overtime and double my salary in my last
you know every week in my last year
that's that's one way of increasing your
benefit you know but for that TR some of
it was those payouts any anything that's
we call trailing wages they get folded
into that final year so those are the
two things that could increase that
higher final year and then there's at
150% cap to capture that um or to
capture some of that and mitigate it if
if they go over that and there's still
the 85 I'm sorry follow uh there's still
the 85% Rule and the
120,000 yes yeah there is there is a
maximum benefit limit this was added
back in
2011 um for anyone who was hired after
71 of9 and not vested by one one of 12
because it was a built on a previous
maximum benefit that's why it has the
weird dates um and for anybody in that
situation that's all of tier B and C the
maximum is 85% of their AFC or
$120,000 whichever is lower so for
instance a you know in group one 40 85%
of AFC is very difficult the multiplier
is lower so you got to work like 50
years to get there you're more likely to
have a the 120 is going to be what's
going to bump up in group two it's it's
it's less it's in the 30 to 40 year
range to get to the 8 85% but that's um
you know there are there are limits on
that as well if you had a a 50-year
employee um you know there's there's a
point at which they'll no longer be
contributing because they've recruited
100% of their AFC you know through the
years of service that that's happened
it's it's rare but not unheard
of
okay Mr martines thank you this is a to
me a good reminder as to why we need to
fix this back then we did hear a lot of
rhetoric about a particular case of
somebody who had a huge pent payout and
then the rhetoric was we got to fix the
spiking the bleeding and we got to fix
this now
hypocritically everything was done
except fix that problem if still today
that classification of workers Chiefs
can get a bonus Troopers can get bonus
firefighters can get bonus they workers
don't get bonus when you get out but
that still happens so it's not even a
case of a collateral damage where you
fix the problem and then you have we
didn't even fix the problem here this is
a classic case of if it was medicine
would be malpractice you know we went
out and removed the wrong limb this here
fix it was done where fix wasn't needed
this is exactly what happened and we're
given an opportunity to repair the the
the problem that we cause and it can be
done and the legislature is a plan
sponsor and can do this thank
you Senator
Waters thanks Madam chair a question for
uh Marty on on this issue of the 85% and
120,000 um as time goes by with
inflation and salary increases are we
seeing any increase in the number of
people who are hitting one of the other
limits uh not yet Senator because
anybody up until February of this year
um was vested prior to 11 one of2 to be
eligible to retire so they you know
there there theirs can be higher we've
we've had some retirements that were in
excess of those amounts because they
weren't covered under this maximum
benefit limit um ultimately you'll
probably start seeing that if if if
there is a pattern or an issue it's it's
going to present itself over the next
few years and then going going forward
uh there was in in House Bill 43 36
which um got folded into hp2 there was
there was an inflation escalator added
to that uh maximum benefit and it was
amended out because it it added some
bottom line cost to the uh to the to the
proposal um you know I forget the exact
percentage I think it was one and a half
percent a year the
120 120,000 would go up um so that that
and certainly if you think think out 20
30 years with just inflation and and you
know what people were making 20 years
ago what what they might be making
though at some point that's probably
going to be subject of of legislative
debate yes in the future as we talked
about that inflation escalator was worth
60 million and that would apply to all
employers of group two it wouldn't be a
lum sum because would be a continuing
expense okay anyone else Senator gray um
I guess to get my support to moving from
5 to three there would have to be
limitations on what would be calculated
into the salaries for that three okay if
I'm looking at somebody who doesn't have
the opportunity to work details or other
things it could be very beneficial to
those people to be at three okay but
someone who can whether we call it
spiking or increase their final three
years or whatever because of working you
know there would need to be something in
there that that at least got me some
kind of a compromise okay
um in in you know whether we're talking
you know tier b or whether we're talking
whatever else there you know if I'm
going to go to three I got to get
something back somewhere else okay uh
other than than that you know I got to
stick with
five because the things that we've done
and the way we've costed this and the
way we've looked at it you know was
based on
five so you know if there is some kind
of other proposal that comes back and
says well um those three years as long
as you're looking at the the full
Baseline salary and your compensation
will be based on that full line salary
for you know without any other ads for
years you know one two three at the end
that that sounds like a reasonable
compromise but again something like that
would have to be worked out to get my
support on
that Mr martines thank you m chair and
this is a quick question to the senator
to The Honorable Senator and others can
correct me but I would ask this would
then instead of we use the word detail
would you agree then that a mandatory
overtime should be calulated in the base
mandatory where you don't have an option
you have to do it like in any
negotiation uh that certainly could be
one of the points that's brought up
thank
you Mr car just one other thing about
AFC I it occurred to me pretty obvious
but there there also is a formula in
place for anybody who wasn't invested by
one one of 12 it's called the
compensation over base versus base pay
this was the subject of House Bill 1587
last year uh and it's it's
another another layer in the benefit
calculation formula employers now have
to report since 2011 base pay and then
everything else is a separate bucket and
then that's averaged out over the the
period for which we have data which was
you know January 1 to 12 so that that's
another cap issue it was it was modified
for group two tier B last year to be a
little more
um favorable than the that it is for you
know for the other group so that that's
another along with the 150% cap and
other things all right thank
you one point is that if someone is
toward the end of their career and they
get a promotion
which is likely toward the end of one's
career having fiveyear AFC calculations
would be an inducement to stay for five
years after the promotion rather than
three I don't know how often that
applies wise but that's
a yeah I I I I we
don't I mean we have salary history for
you know thous tens of thousands of
members but we don't chart that or or
the actual doesn't because it doesn't
play in but you know it is fair to say
unless you're maxed out on a in a
salaried position and you're on the same
band you know for five years typically
people's salaries tend to increase over
time so okay not always uh and for with
the fiveyear too
um it is the highest five years in the
career you know for a lot of people it
is towards the end but if somebody was
in a higher paying position and for
lifestyle or Reon other reasons chose to
take a lower paying less stressful
position you know we're going to look at
the entirety of their salary record and
find those highest three or high five
wherever they may fall if they switched
employers things it's you know it's not
always the last five okay thank you
that's just just another
complication anyone
else okay moving on to colas Mr uh F Mr
Fuller you had a
uh a proposal yes thank you uh let's get
back up to number one yeah there we go
yes so uh so colus
um so I mean I know colas have been a
topic that's been discussed for um for
quite some time but um and what was
being proposed here too again just kind
of looking at similar States because
again looking at so obviously be able to
attract employees and then also retain
them and this is kind of borrowed a lot
from uh vermonts just so to give a
little bit of perspective to folks so
along with this and then just some
thoughts here just maybe what would
obviously what the fund would consist of
because I mean I know there's definitely
a problem I mean I'm not looking to it
would be be nice to snap my fingers and
be oh yeah everyone's got a cola but you
know there's no money there so we need
obviously kind of raise some money to
put some some money into it so um some
general fund Surplus potentially um any
other General front Appropriations and
then looking at um investment earnings
generated by the account as well so just
trying to borrow from how some things
were similarly done for other accounts
even kind of looking at you know
potential medical subsidies it's kind of
IDE I'm still throwing around but just
don't really quite all did the details
worked out but and at the same time too
we're looking to uh terally fund this
because I I I know this has been
something that's been talked about a lot
and and I wholeheartedly agree that um
you know things you know termly funding
things is very important so um this is
also why looking to do at half of CPI I
mean in an ideal world I mean I'd love
to propose all of CPI but I recognize
that you know um there might not be
quite the appetite for that and again
just kind of looking at Vermont so even
to have you know essentially like you
know half of CPI and again this is also
if the funds are available so
and really what they ask here is again
for the nhrs kind of looking at some
kind of assessment of what to be the
cost of doing this and you know again
just throwing out there five years
because naturally it would take some
time to be able to you know raise some
funds to be able to to do this and to be
able to to provide this and I just again
just along with these other thoughts
happened to think this would would be a
really great tool to both for attraction
and retention of uh state
employees thank thank you any comments
questions issues Senator
Bradley
so use of the general fund I think at
this point in time given the YDC
settlements which um I think most
observers to that process think that
the1 million that we've allocated for
those settlements and the litigation
is not going to be
adequate I think that anything that um
undermines the ability to fulfill the
settlements that are likely to come
forward that comes out of the general
fund is going to be problematic so um I
would just say that on proposal number
one and in terms of investment um
earnings and this is how we got into
problems in the past where we had you
know several good years and then the
gain sharing happened and then suddenly
investment returns went down and rates
had to go up so I I that's why the
actuaries
um analyze the rates over generally a 5
to 10 year period of time because
there'll be fluctuations in the market
and just trying to take Surplus in any
given year of investment earnings and
putting it into a cola account I think
is problematic um to me if we're going
to fund a cola it is something that has
to be an agreement between employers and
employees as to how a rate structure for
both sides of the equation um is going
to change
obviously um you know there would be
some pain for employers and employees
but that to me is the way if we're going
to have a cola that it needs to be paid
for Mr
martines thank you madam
chair uh I'm looking at this at a much
simpler way the way I look at it is in
2011 we raised contribution by 2% with
no actra
benefits we are more than a decade after
this is as far as I'm concerned this
Coler is already paid for we paid it
already that's that's the way I look at
it another alternative to my thought
number two would be to refund the 2% to
the workers that paid that without the
actual benefit at that point we did
close the coal account we talked about
coming up with a fix and with a solution
with that and everybody really thought
this was going to happen but here we are
in 2022 2020 23 thinking about we need
to take a collection and raise taxes and
then you know this is a a way to get rid
of it with a sticker shock I'd simply
say we got this we paid and we should do
this thank you
okay yes Senator Waters thank Madam
chair this a a question for Senator
Bradley I mean I I hear your concerns
about this and you know frankly we can
any given year do we want with the
general fund just and put the money
where we want but um I wondered Senator
Bradley that if we had a proposal that
said that you know given all the
concerns about the
employers that if such a plan were set
up that the match of the employee
contribution would be made by the state
and that would be a way of not passing
the burden Shifting the burden down to
the employers but the state would have
the option of deciding
in a given year whether um you know
there would be funding that could be put
into such an account I I think we kind
of need to know from Mr Carlin at some
point I mean how much money do we have
to get into this such an account over
how what period of time in order to do
any kind of terminal funding if I is
Meaningful but that would be another way
to go the state would match with the
employees go forward
so um Marty maybe you can refresh my
memory when I think it was in 2019 or 20
there was uh 1.5%
Cola um what was the cost of
that uh that the the unfunded piece of
that was I
um I I pretty comfortable in saying it
was in the vicinity of 67 to70 million
and and I was just looking up that Cola
that the one passed in 2019 effective 7
one of 20 was 1 a half% on the first
50,000 of annual benefit to all members
who retired honor before uh July 1st of
14 so would been retired five years or
more and that was about again 67 to 70
million that that wasn't
prefunding into the employer rates to be
paid off in a 20-year layer so we're a
few years into paying paying that one
off
now
so I guess my point Senator is that it's
pretty expensive and
to
um dedicate
prospectively um a general fund match
would be I think problematic
so I'd like to also comment that this
depends on the general fund having a
significant
Surplus and this bium I believe it
doesn't
um and we never know what's going to
happen in the next bium so this would
be even if it were set up it would be a
very
chancy form of a cost of living increase
because my expectation would be the
Surplus would go down when inflation
goes up so you'd have less money when
you needed it
more
but anyone else
okay I mean again I'll
reiterate I think your Co is a good idea
but it's something that has to be
reflected in an agreement between in my
opinion employers and
employees on how the contribution levels
would be set to pay for
it okay
and I wanted to reiterate that
there are tax advantage savings plans
available to everybody no matter whether
they work for the state or for a
different place and many employees are
using them and that's a worthwhile way
to save for a postretirement cost of
living um matches are dependent
on negotiations or in the case of state
employees a stat statute change to to
authorize that but they they can be made
and it's not
as
um it doesn't require a great deal of
effort to set something like that
up the current plan is ad hoc payments
from the retirement system that when the
legislature is concerned enough that the
retirees need a benef an increase we
come up with something
sometimes we pay for it sometimes we
dump it on the towns and other
employers but it's a onetime payment and
it
is for the last decade or so most of
them have not been in increases in the
base pension they've been one-time
payments of some sort and they've been
limited generally to the
lower lower paid
retirees and then there are a whole lot
of other plans uh Mr Fullers being one
being one type the sep the special
account that we used to have is a
different type
um but those all get relatively
complicated to do what what you
want um anyone else have a comment on Co
colas Senator
Waters thank thank you madam chair and
uh you know as you know from the desal
commission both you and I kind of and
your subsequent bills on the ideas about
an opt out instead of an opt in um
haven't gotten much traction but um you
know I do think there is potentially
another option where we set up a you
know kind of um postretirement type of
supplemental account and that
um have the opt out option on it and
that here again that it might be set at
a fairly low level but that the employes
the contribution might be matched by a
state contribution particularly to that
I don't think it would be a lot of money
over you know in a given year but that
is another way to to get at people to
participate in in something that I
personally think everybody should do but
you know that we we haven't gotten a
traction on that one concern is that
most of the members of retirement system
do not work for the
state the largest group is
Teachers um then there's state employees
and other local employees group two is
almost entirely working for the towns
and cities I mean we've got the state
police and the conservation officers in
corrections but most of the rest are
working for other units so we can't make
a blanket agreement unless we get all of
the re relevant employers to do so yeah
if I may I I I understand that but it
also kind of is a backd door way of
getting at the concerns of of
municipalities about downshifting and
you know the original kind of pullback
of the state from providing certain
kinds of funding and this is you know
another way of kind of recognizing that
but perhaps a simpler and less expensive
way of getting out a very particular
issue well if you have a specific
plan we would love to hear hear it and
we'll we'll analyze it and throw darts
at it just like we have the
others
but we we it would be a good idea to
have a some other plans that we could
see see what they're looking for how
much they
cost
okay anyone else have a comment before
we we
close all right I'd very much like to
thank Mr Fuller and M Mr BR for bringing
in these proposals for us to analyze and
throw darts
at and we will be meeting meeting next
Thursday and hopefully we will have the
revenue estimates so we can make some
recommendations on some of these things
and thank you all for being
here
that